[MUSIC PLAYING]
CHRIS EDWARDS: I was
24 when I started
my career in advertising.
It was 1993, and I took a job at
Arnold as a junior copywriter.
And my father, Ed
Eskandarian, he
was the CEO and
owner at the time.
And let me tell you, it is not
easy being the boss's daughter,
especially when
deep down, you've
always known you were his son.
I first verbalized this when
I was around five years old.
I came out to my grandmother.
I just didn't know
that's what I was doing.
Neither did she-- surprise!
We were at her summer
cottage on the Cape.
And my older sister Wendy and I
were sitting in the family room
coloring, and Gram was
getting dinner ready.
And she was coming from the
kitchen to the dining room
with platters of
food, passing by us.
And on her last
pass, she said, "come
on girls, dinner's ready."
And my sister sprang
up immediately
and followed her to the table.
I didn't flinch.
I honestly did not think
she was talking to me.
So I kept coloring.
And a minute or so later,
she came over to me
and she said, didn't
you hear me calling you?
And I said, no.
And she said, I
said, come on girls.
And I looked at her like
she was insane, and I said,
I'm not a girl.
And she said, yes--
yes, you are.
And I said, no, I'm not.
I'm a boy.
And she said no you're
not, sweetheart.
And I said, well,
then I'm going to be.
I'm also a Taurus,
just so you know.
And she just-- she said,
you can't, darling.
And she smiled
sympathetically at me
and walked back
into the kitchen.
And I remember being
left there thinking,
you know, whatever, Gram.
You know, I'm going to make
this happen with or without you.
And I was wracking my
brain, trying to figure out,
how could she possibly
make this mistake?
Are other people
making this mistake?
So I started trying
to figure out,
and according to my
five-year-old brain,
the only difference
between boys and girls
was that boys had short hair
and girls had long hair.
So I told my mom,
I want my hair cut
like daddy's, problem solved--
so I thought.
It wasn't until the
following summer,
when I realized I was
lacking certain equipment.
I was back at Gram's-- that
seemed to be where everything
happened.
But this time, I was with Wendy
and my younger cousin Adam.
And we were out on the
back deck having popsicles.
And Adam nudges me, and
he says, watch this.
And then he turns to the side,
and he pees in a perfect arc,
right over the deck rail.
And I was like--
you know, oh my god.
You know, how did you do that?
You know, when I pee,
it goes straight down.
So I actually thought it
was some kind of magic trick
that he was doing.
I think I said, do you
have a squirt gun in there?
Like, what-- and my sister
is like, duh, he has a penis.
And I'm like, oh,
yeah, of course.
And I'm thinking,
what is a penis?
And how come I don't have one?
But it was very hard
being six years,
trying to rationalize it.
So I figured, OK, well, maybe
mine just hasn't grown yet.
I'm sure it'll grow.
I'm kind of sure--
you know, kids grow in heights
at all different times.
I'm sure it'll grow.
Well, that never happened.
And I began to realize something
was terribly, terribly wrong.
And every night I would pray
that somehow, some way, my body
would turn into a boy's body
and everybody would finally
realize they were all wrong
for thinking that I was a girl.
My body changed all right,
just not the way I had hoped.
Puberty hit and my body betrayed
me in the worst possible ways
that I could ever imagine.
And I knew then
that I was stuck.
I was stuck in this body
that I hated, and stuck being
a girl for the rest of my life.
I became deeply,
deeply depressed.
My whole personality changed.
I was no longer the fun
loving kid I used to be.
I was angry all the time,
snapping at everybody.
I'd hold it together
at school, so I
wouldn't lose all my friends.
But I'd get home and
I'd take it out--
take it out on my family.
In junior high
and high school, I
knew I was attracted to girls
so I thought I must be gay.
This is actually a very
common mistake, at first.
A lot of people think
being transgender
is like an extreme
form of being gay.
It's hard for
people to understand
that gender identity
and sexual orientation
are two completely separate
and unrelated things.
One way to understand it
is, sexual orientation
is who you go to bed
with, and gender identity
is who you go to bed as.
But I didn't know any
of that at the time.
All I knew was, oh, my
god, I think I'm gay.
And that was traumatizing
enough for me.
I mean, this was the early 80s.
Nobody was openly
gay-- certainly nobody
in white upper class
suburbia where I grew up.
I mean, there was definitely no
Gayblers, I can tell you that.
There weren't even any
celebrities that were out--
you know, there was no
Ellen, no "Will and Grace,"
no "Modern Family."
George Michael was still in
the closet, for God's sake,
and those were the Wham!
Years.
So he's bopping around on
stage in white Capri pants,
singing wake me up
before you go, go--
and girls everywhere actually
thought they had a chance.
The problem was, when I looked
up the definition of the word
gay-- and I did, that's how
I am, I'm very thorough--
all it said was basically,
someone who's attracted
to someone of the same sex.
It didn't say
anything about feeling
like you were in the
wrong body or wanting
to become the opposite sex.
So then I figured, oh great,
I'm this freak, and I'm ashamed,
and there's no way
I am ever going
to tell anybody how I really
feel inside-- especially not
my family.
I couldn't bear the thought
of humiliating them,
and the thought of them
being ashamed of me.
It got to a point
where I could not
envision a future for myself--
one in which I'd
be happy, anyway.
So senior year of high
school, I made a decision.
I decided I would go to college,
party it up for four years,
and then kill myself
after graduation.
Now the first part
of the plan was easy.
I had already
gotten into Colgate,
which was ranked the number
one party school in the US
that year.
So I majored in psychology
and minored in keg stands--
or maybe it was the
other way around.
But graduation came
and went, and I just
couldn't bring myself
to follow through
with the rest of the plan.
So where did that leave me?
Well when you get to
a point in your life
where you don't want to live it
any more, you have two choices.
You can either end it,
or you can change it.
And since I couldn't
bring myself to end it,
I knew I had to change it.
Lucky for me, I had three
things going for me.
The first was a loving
and supportive family--
and this is, sadly, something a
lot of trans kids do not have.
And it's a big reason why
the suicide attempt rate
for trans youth is near 50%--
five oh.
Now, I'm not saying, when
I finally told my parents,
they were like, well, let's
go get you some surgery,
and take care of it!
I've described their reaction
as cautiously supportive.
It was a lot to take in,
back then in the early 90s.
Very little
information out there--
certainly no success
stories to point to.
There was nobody that they
could look at and say, oh,
well that person did it
and they turned out fine.
You know, Chris will be fine.
There was nobody.
And surgery was nowhere near
where it is today, especially
going from female to male.
It's a lot harder to add
than it is to subtract,
if you know what I mean.
So they were scared.
They were scared I was going
to go through all of this,
publicly, only to end up
worse off-- losing my friends
and becoming like
a social outcast,
and not being happy with my
body after going through it.
I remember a few weeks
after I had told them,
my dad had been processing it.
And he said to me,
very hopefully,
do you think you could
just stay the way you are?
Maybe keep it-- keep it inside
and go as you're going now,
and maybe just
consider this handicap?
And I looked at him and I
said, this is my identity.
It's not something that I
can compartmentalize, put
on a shelf, and forget about.
It's who I am every day.
And if I have to keep
living my life as a girl,
I'd just rather
not live it at all.
And he hugged me, and he said,
that we would get through this
together as a family.
And it was that feeling
of finally not being alone
in this anymore that gave
me the hope and the courage
to take the next step.
Which brings me to the second
thing I had going for me--
some damn good therapy.
Finding the right
therapist was very hard,
because there weren't
many that had experience
with gender identity issues.
But I found one, and
having the right therapist
was critical to my getting
through my transition
as successfully as I did.
Anyone who knows me--
Matt knows me a little bit--
knows that I am a worrier.
I worry about everything.
It's in my DNA.
And to give you an
idea, in high school
I was voted most
likely to get an ulcer.
So you can imagine, when it
came to something as pivotal
as changing my gender in
front of every single person
I knew, I was
consumed with worry.
You know, worry
about, what are people
going to think, or say, or do?
It was paralyzing.
And I figured, my
therapist is just
going to tell me,
well, you can't worry
about what you can't control.
But she didn't.
Instead, she said
to me, well, you
can actually control how
other people treat you.
And I looked at
her, and she said,
the way you act
can actually shape
the way other people react.
And it clicked something in me.
It was like unlocking
the secret inner power
I didn't know I had.
And it was that power
that gave me the balls
to change my life, which
is why I hold my therapist
in such high regard.
Doesn't mean, I didn't want to
kill her at times, especially
in the beginning.
I remember the very first
session I had with her.
I walked into her office
in Central Square,
and she opened the
door and she was
exactly what I pictured a
Cambridge therapist would
look like.
Medium length, straight
brown hair, graying,
parted in the middle, big round
glasses, turtleneck sweater,
chunky necklace,
corduroys, sensible all
weather walking shoes, Subaru
Outback parked in front.
Anyway, I go in there,
and we sit down,
and she's staring at me
and I'm staring at her.
And we're just having a
staring contest until finally I
was like, OK, where
should we start?
Where do you want to start?
I don't know, wherever
you think is best?
Where do you think is best?
Oh, my god.
I mean, you go--
you go to a therapist because
you want a professional
to tell you what to do.
But she was all about the
questions-- every session,
constantly challenging
my feelings
and understanding
about gender and I
will say, as annoying as it, it
was actually a very good thing.
My initial plan was to move away
and go and transition somewhere
where nobody knew me.
And she got me to
realize, I was going
to be a lot of support to get
through something like this.
And to move somewhere where
I had no family, no friends,
and try to do this in secret--
while it might sound appealing
short term, in the long run,
it could end up being much,
much more stressful and harder
to do.
So she was the one
who opened me up
to the idea of staying in Boston
and transitioning at Arnold.
Which leads me to
the third thing--
I worked in advertising.
So I was able to take the
branding and marketing
principles that I was applying
to my clients' business,
and use them to rebrand myself.
And before I get
to that, there's--
I think there's a big myth
out there that someone decides
they're transgender
and boom, they
show up to work the next
day in a wig and a dress--
or in my case a haircut and
a coat and tie or something.
But that's not the case.
While some people choose
to go about it that way,
everybody handles
their transition very,
very differently.
And to understand
my strategy, you
have to understand one more
thing about my personality.
I am not type A. I'm type A+--
maybe even A++.
I am a strategizer, a planner--
I plan out everything.
So when it came to something
as important as my transition,
you can bet your ass I planned
the shit out of that thing.
It was like nine months
worth of planning.
OK, so what did I do?
Well, in advertising
what we always
do is, we take a look
at the landscape,
see what's going on around us.
So let me paint the
picture for you.
At this point, it's 1995.
Transgender isn't even
a word at this point.
The word that was out
there was transsexual--
very, very negative
connotations to that word.
Don't use it.
But that was the only
word that was out there.
And the only points of reference
people had to that word
was from the media--
movies like "The
Silence of the Lambs."
Anybody seen this?
You may remember
Hannibal Lecter,
but the villain that they
were chasing, Buffalo Bill,
was a frustrated
transsexual who was mental,
and skinned women so he could
sew a female body together
for himself.
Nice.
Even comedies like "Ace Ventura,
Pet Detective," spoiler alert
for those of you
haven't seen it,
Lois Einhorn is actually Ray
Finkle, a mentally unstable
transsexual.
And then of course, there are
these stellar guests on Jerry
Springer as seen in this episode
entitled "Tranny-licious."
I had my work cut out for me.
When it came to
changing perceptions,
I didn't only have
to rebrand myself,
I had to rebrand an
entire category--
which, I'm sure you guys
know, is not an easy task.
So what was my brand
message going to be?
Well, that was easy.
Basically, I wanted
to prove to people
that I am not a whack job
like the media might portray--
that I'm normal.
And I'm still the same person
on the inside, just a little bit
different on the outside.
So because I was the first
and only person at this point
to publicly go through
a gender transition,
I knew it was up to me, based
on what my therapist had taught
me, that the way I act can shape
the way other people react--
it was up to me
to set an example.
So I decided right
away I was not
going to be meek, or ashamed, or
secretive about my transition.
Instead I was going to
be open and honest--
an educator, you know,
willing to answer questions
and volunteer information.
I'm an over-sharer
to begin with,
so that was really just an
extension of my personality.
The other thing about my
personality that came in handy
was my sense of humor.
So I made a point to
use my sense of humor
to put other people at ease.
The last thing I wanted
was for coworkers
to avoid me out of fear of
saying the wrong thing, which
is a tendency we all have
to do in awkward situations.
I wanted them to know, if
they got the pronoun wrong,
I wasn't going to
bite their head off--
just show them I wasn't
so sensitive about it.
And the first time
I did this was just
an involuntary reaction,
I couldn't help myself.
I was walking down the
hall toward the AV suite,
and the editor happened to be
explaining to her intern what
all of the adapter cables were.
And she held up the 90s
equivalent of this one
and said, this is
a female to male.
And I was right outside her
door and I just leaned in
and I said hey, stop
talking about me!
And they laughed
and it got around.
And you know, the summer outing
was a couple of weeks later,
had a field day with that.
So I found that it
really did help.
I was told it helped, too.
I know this is going to be hard
for a lot of you to imagine,
but there was no
real internet yet.
You couldn't Google anything.
There was no Google.
So what was formerly
a disadvantage to me
as I was growing
up and struggling
to understand what
was going on with me,
and what transgender was--
it was now an advantage
to me, in that
I had virtually complete
control over the information.
I would share only
what I wanted people
to know, and tell
the story my way.
So how was I going to do that?
Well, I knew the best
way would be for it
to come from me personally.
Nobody can tell my
story like I can.
And because of my father's
position at the company,
I decided OK, the
first thing, I really
should tell the executive board.
I could do a whole
talk on that alone.
But I-- out of respect, I
wanted them to know first.
I did not want
gossip trickling up.
OK, so let's say I tell
the executive board.
What about the rest
of the hundreds
of people at the agency?
How are they going to find out?
I didn't want the board
sending out a memo,
and I was not about to stand
up and call an agency meeting
and announce it.
And this is where my background
really came in handy.
The big thing at the
time in the business
was evangelism marketing.
And evangelism marketing is
basically encouraging people
to take a role in
actively spreading
the word on your behalf
in a positive way.
Today you'd call
it word of mouth.
It's cooler, doesn't
sound religious,
but back then it was called
evangelism marketing.
We had just won Volkswagen.
It was a big thing.
And so at Arnold, the big
push was turning consumers
into brand evangelists
for our clients.
And it hit me, well, why
not turn my coworkers
into brand evangelists for me?
And that's what I did.
Before I told the
board, one by one
I came out to 12 of my
closest friends at the agency,
told them my story
in great detail,
coached them on how to
tell it to other people,
had them practice on me,
which was a very good idea.
And then I told them the
date of the board meeting,
and that once it was over
to just go forth and start
spreading the word.
So the board meeting was a
Monday from 4:00 to 6:00 PM.
And I would say by 11:00
AM the next morning
the whole agency knew.
The whole advertising
community knew.
People I went--
people outside knew.
It was crazy.
And I can see a lot of
you look nonplussed.
But just remember,
there was no texting.
There was no Snapchat.
There weren't even
any smartphones.
So think about it.
6 PM, workday's over--
11 AM, two hours
in, everybody knows.
Give me some fucking credit.
That was fast, right?
It was a good strategy.
So how did it go over?
Well I can tell you, it
took all the strength
I had to force myself to go
into work that next morning
after the board meeting.
I just-- I got drunk the night,
that night after it, and--
that wasn't why, though.
I just was so nervous to go in.
But I knew if I didn't, people
would think I was ashamed,
and the gossip would just start.
So I forced myself to go in.
So I was going to
go in, I was just
going to go in really early--
8:45, early for a
creative person.
I just wanted to slip into
my office and not see anyone.
I knew there'd be nobody on
the creative floor before 9:00.
And I was right.
So I just sat
there in my office,
waiting for the unknown.
And about 20 past
9:00, the first person
showed up at my door
with tears in his eyes,
to tell me how brave
he thought I was.
And then after him, the head
of print production came by.
She's like, all business,
all frazzled all the time,
you know, one of those types.
And she shows up at
my door and, knowing
I'd be changing my name she
said to me, when you know,
let me know how you want me
to do your new business cards.
I couldn't believe it.
It was like a
parade outside my--
it was hugs and well
wishes all day--
so many stories, a lot
of them in the book.
I'll tell you one of them.
This is my favorite one.
One of my buddies who
worked in the art studio
gave me a bar mitzvah card.
Neither of us is Jewish.
But on the cover it
said, congratulations,
today you are man.
And because he's
crafty, you know,
works in the studio
on the inside,
he customized it to include
all of these guy tips
he thought I should know.
Like, always look straight ahead
at the urinal, none of that.
I don't want to imply that
everybody acknowledged it
with me.
That certainly isn't the case.
Most people treated me
like they always did,
which is all I wanted anyway.
But there were-- and there
were some negative reactions.
I'd be naive to think
there wouldn't be.
But none of them were to
my face, which was great.
And I think having your dad as
the CEO helps in that regard.
But honestly the day could
not have gone better.
OK, so I made the announcement,
and then you know what I did?
Nothing.
I wanted everyone to have time
to sit with it, think about it,
talk about it, get it all
out and get used to the idea
before I made any changes and
started socially transitioning.
So no changes until
I gave it time.
And that includes which bathroom
I was going to be using.
Even back then, 20 years
ago, the only thing
that people at the board and
other people freaked out about
was my using the men's room.
So I told the board, I thought
this might be an issue.
They wanted to send out a memo
and I said absolutely not.
For the first two
weeks, I am not
going to use the men's rooms
or the ladies rooms at Arnold--
for two weeks, so
don't worry about it.
Probably like, well,
what did you do?
I would have killed for that set
up, that you guys have there.
That would have
been very helpful.
But there were no gender
neutral or unisex restrooms
on the eight floors that we had.
So what I did, my office--
I had an interior
office at the time--
and it had a support beam kind
of right when you walked in,
so there was this
little alcove thing.
So I had facilities come
and put a curtain up there.
And then I just had this
bucket, and I would go behind--
no I didn't, come on.
Come on!
Come on.
What I did was, I would--
whenever I had to go, I
would take the elevator down
14 floors, go out the back,
the lobby, around the corner
two blocks to Rebecca's
cafe, where they
had a gender neutral bathroom.
Inconvenient, yes,
especially when
you have a bladder the
size of a grape like I do.
I've had to pee for
the last 10 minutes.
But I knew it was better
for me and everybody
else in the long run, just
to get used to the idea.
And I needed to psych
myself up for the idea.
By the way, ladies, it
is a total step down,
the men's room.
You're not missing anything.
But, you know,
when I finally did
go in there, the first few
times, yeah, people talked.
But it died down really quickly
because there really isn't--
wasn't anything to say.
You know, I didn't have
outdoor plumbing yet,
so I was using the stalls.
And unlike guys blatantly
bringing in reading material,
I wasn't making a
day of it in there.
One guy I saw go in with
a Harry Potter book.
Really?
The theme of my
transition was gradual--
that was my whole theme.
So the physical changes
were all gradual.
I'd always had
short hair, but it
was more of a gender neutral
kind of a nondescript haircut.
I could have just gone
and gotten a buzz cut--
it was the summer, it was hot
as shit, I'd always wanted one.
But I knew if I made a
drastic change like that,
people would just start talking.
Did you see Chris
got a crew cut?
It makes his ears look big.
Uh, he should've--
you know, whatever.
Whatever it is,
a drastic change,
it would just give people
more fodder to talk.
So instead I cut my
hair shorter and shorter
in stages over a few months.
Same thing with growing a beard.
I'm Armenian on both sides.
I was on testosterone.
There was hair
growing everywhere.
So if I wanted to grow a beard,
I could have grown a beard.
but-- would I have liked to?
Yes.
It would have covered up
my newfound acne problem.
There's nothing like going
through male puberty at age 26,
being at CBS, fighting off
all the junior high kids
for the last tube of Oxy10.
So a beard would
have been nice, but I
knew if I grew a beard, again,
that would give people more
to talk.
Oh, there'd probably be
an over under on how long
it would take, the whole thing.
So I held off on that.
And the creative department,
anything goes, you know,
wardrobe code-- dress code,
which actually kind of drew me
to the job-- to the occupation.
I was wearing jeans,
sneakers, button downs anyway.
So unless there was a
client meeting where
I had to wear a coat
and tie or something,
my wardrobe changes
were relatively minor.
So all in, by year
two of my transition,
people were coming
up to me and saying,
I have no idea what
you used to look like.
And I liken it to--
it's kind of like when
someone loses a lot of weight.
So if someone loses 25 pounds
and you haven't seen him
in a year, and then you see
him, and you're like, holy shit!
Oh, my god!
But if they're losing two pounds
a month and you're with them
every day, you kind of don't
notice it while it's-- while
it's happening.
It's kind of that phenomenon.
And finally there's the
surgical part of the transition.
General rule of thumb--
a lot of you probably
already know this--
you should never,
ever ask somebody
who's transgender
whether they've had
or plan to have surgery.
It's none of your business,
which makes it invasive,
but it's also offensive.
And if you see activists in the
media, they say it's offensive,
it's offensive.
But no one ever
takes the extra step
to explain why it's offensive.
Does anyone know
why it's offensive?
Want me to tell you?
OK, I'll tell you.
Your gender is not defined
by what's inside your pants.
Your anatomical sex is defined
by what's inside your pants,
your genitals.
Your gender is defined by
what's inside your brain.
So by asking somebody who's
transgender the surgery
question, what you're
implying to them
is that you don't believe
they're the gender
they affirm they are
unless they have surgery
to physically alter their body.
Does everyone understand that?
And the fact is, a lot of trans
people never have surgery.
It's individual
decision, everybody
is different-- it could be
for a number of reasons.
A lot of times it's because
you can't afford it.
Now insurance-- at least
in Massachusetts, insurance
is covering it.
So hopefully that
will be a non factor.
It could be a number
of-- fear, the pain,
it's a lot to go through,
maybe you can't get--
you don't have the support
or you can't get time off.
Or maybe you're just happy
with your body the way it is
and it doesn't bother you.
So that is something
you should avoid.
Now if someone like me
is yammering on about it,
then by all means, get
in the conversation.
But you just take your
cues from that person.
For me, my personal
decision was,
I knew I wanted to have
surgery right from the get go.
It was the only way I was going
to feel complete as a man.
And there was a
time period where--
of five years-- five years
where I had 22 surgeries.
That's one every three months.
The deluxe model
does not come easy.
I can tell you that right now.
But it was worth it.
And that was while I
was managing the largest
account at the agency.
So I was really happy that
I listened to my therapist.
What was I going to do, make up
22 different stories about why
I'm out of the office for
weeks at a time, had I gone
and tried to do this secretly?
I mean, there was no way.
So it was actually
much less stressful,
for me and everyone
else on my team--
I had a lot of
people on my team.
And it was great for
them, because they
knew it was not a
big secret, they
knew the parameters of
when I could be reached
and when to leave me alone.
And they actually used
it to their advantage.
They would call
me to present work
when I was most doped
up on painkillers,
and God knows what I approved.
I've got to tell you,
I felt bad for Ron.
I had one long term goal when
I set out on this journey,
and that was not to let
my transition define me.
I just wanted to get through
it and be the man I always
knew myself to be.
It took time, and all successful
rebranding campaigns do.
But I think I
achieved that goal.
I am not my parents'
transgender son.
I'm just their son.
My friends don't introduce me
as their trans friend Chris,
you know--
just Chris, or
Eddie, or Pee Head,
or whatever they're
going to call me.
And at Arnold, I
wasn't Chris Edwards
the transgender
creative director.
I was just a creative director.
Well, an EVP group
creative director.
I don't want to
sell myself short.
But the word transition
means going from one place
to another.
And I was here.
So for me, if I had to check
a box, I would check male.
I would not check transgender,
or trans man-- some people do.
It's up to you how
you define yourself.
I define myself as male.
Does everyone understand that?
So then came my departure from
Arnold to write this book.
So now I'm kind of back in
this transgender spotlight.
I really felt strongly that
I needed to share this story.
My hope, in writing this book,
was that people would read it.
It would be a fun, easy read.
I've been-- from the Amazon
reviews, I'm being told it is.
People are reading it
in one day, six hours.
And as an ad guy,
my goal has always
been when I do spots, or
videos, or ads of any kind,
it's to engage and entertain
and wrap that message
that I want people to walk
away with in something fun
and engaging.
And that was my--
what I sought out to
do with this book.
And the hope was that
people would walk away
having read it, feeling
empowered and inspired,
because it's a
universal message.
But also walk away with
a better understanding
of what it means
to be transgender,
which will hopefully lead
to wider spread acceptance
as well.
And that was the goal of
me speaking here with you
guys today.
So thank you for having me.
[APPLAUSE]
I am happy to take any
questions you might have--
anything.
As I said, I've
written a memoir.
It's all out there, all out
on the table, so nothing--
if you manage to ask something
that is inappropriate,
which I highly
doubt, I'll tell you
and we'll make it
a teachable moment.
AUDIENCE: I recently
did a project where
I was looking for inclusive
images that reflected
all people, instead of
the straight white males
that get so much screen time.
And I encountered a challenge
with transgender people,
where I couldn't
answer the question
about where cross-dressing fit
in on an inclusive spectrum.
Can you give some guidance
to whether cross-dressing
is something that is
generally considered positive
for the transgender community,
or whether it's insulting?
Because I could
never figure it out.
CHRIS EDWARDS: I think it
depends on who you ask.
But for me, I'd like
people to understand
that cross-dressing is not
related to being transgender.
It's something that people
do for other reasons.
They don't-- cross-dressers
don't necessarily feel that
they are the wrong gender,
they just enjoy exploring being
the other gender
every now and then.
That's pretty much
what it means to me.
That's the easiest
way that I define it.
But I do find that
it confuses people
who don't understand gender
identity, and it clouds things.
So I wish people did
understand better,
because it is very different.
Does that help?
Sort of?
Hi.
AUDIENCE: Hey,
Chris, great talk.
CHRIS EDWARDS: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: Let me know if this
is an inappropriate question.
Do you think there's more
stigma for transitions
that are male to female,
rather than female to male?
Do you have any insights?
CHRIS EDWARDS: So by
stigma, do you mean that--
what do you mean by stigma?
I'm just trying to--
AUDIENCE: That's
a good question.
I feel like-- maybe I
could phrase it as--
CHRIS EDWARDS: Are
not as accepted?
AUDIENCE: People might question
the motives more deeply on male
to female, than female to male?
Maybe that's a good
way to phrase it.
Again, let me know if this
is an inappropriate topic.
CHRIS EDWARDS: No, it's not
an inappropriate question.
I just don't know if
I'm the authority on it.
But what I would
say is, I do feel
that you probably-- a lot of
people ask me, do more men
transition to women, than
women transitioning to men?
Because that's
pretty much what you
see the most of in the media.
And there's a saying--
let me make sure
I get this right--
female to male, pass
better on the streets,
male to female pass
better under the sheets.
This is a saying
that is out there.
And what that means
is, it's a bit easier
to be a woman transitioning
male physically, to pass.
And just so you guys
know, the term passing
can be considered
offensive by some people,
because that word implies
you're pulling something
over on somebody--
you're faking.
So a lot of trans people
are bothered by that term.
Like if you say, oh, my
god, you pass really well,
I'd never be able to tell.
Some people would
be offended by that.
I'm not, but some people are.
So adult men who
transition female,
it's very hard
sometimes to pass.
Your body is already developed,
and your features are set.
And it's very hard for
some people to pass.
So I think that is why trans
women are targeted more
with violence.
It's terrible.
I would hope--
I would think, and people
have said this to me,
if I'm walking down
the street, you'd
just think I was a short guy.
You wouldn't necessarily jump
to, he's trans, he tran--
you know, you wouldn't.
But-- and I'm thankful for that.
But I think that for people
who are challenged by passing,
that stigmatizes them in a way.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
And I realize that
my question has
kind of a gender binary
assumption built into it,
which is obviously--
CHRIS EDWARDS: That's
a whole nother--
AUDIENCE: A whole lot
of discussion, exactly.
I just wanted to
acknowledge that.
But thank you for the answer.
CHRIS EDWARDS: Sure.
AUDIENCE: I was
wondering, when you
told the boards about
your transition,
were they concerned that
any of your customers
might react weirdly?
I can see that in a
creative community,
people were much more accepting
because, like anything's
possible.
CHRIS EDWARDS: Right.
AUDIENCE: But outside businesses
and German, Volkswagen--
I'm German, I can say that--
they might be a little
stiff and say, what?
I don't-- what?
I don't get it.
Let's go somewhere else.
CHRIS EDWARDS: Yep.
That's a good question.
The answer to that was--
is, when I told them,
it did not come up.
And at the time, I was
not like a big shot
person who had all this
client facing time.
I was two years in as a writer.
So I had some clients that
I would meet with in person.
A lot of them were on the phone.
And the account directors who
came to see me when they heard,
would come in and say, OK, how
should we tell the clients?
How do you want to
go about doing it?
No one said to
me, oh, no, you're
going to-- we're going to
lose business because of you.
Now granted, I wasn't
working on Volkswagen.
So I don't know how the
Germans would have taken it.
But I think being
a creative person,
you do have that flexibility.
People are a little
more accepting.
Since the book came
out, I get e-mails
from a lot of
people, some of whom
are transgender and looking
for my humble advice.
And one of-- a lot of them work
at very conservative companies
and are asking me
for guidance there.
And so I was very lucky
that I worked in a liberal--
I'm in a liberal state, and
I work in a liberal industry.
And I had job security,
which a lot of trans people--
most of them do not have.
But the one thing I
had going for me was,
I knew I couldn't get fired.
My dad's not going to fire
me, so that was something
that I had going for me.
Does that answer your question?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
Thank you.
AUDIENCE: Where did
you find resources
about being trans especially?
Like, I know at
least my coming out
story is so much defined
by using the internet
at like, 2:00 AM on bad days.
But considering not only
was there not the internet,
but trans was only really being
used in academic journals--
CHRIS EDWARDS: Right.
AUDIENCE: --like, '93,
where did you find resources
to help understand
yourselves and help
find resources to help you
transition and accept yourself?
CHRIS EDWARDS: That's
a great question.
And part of me is struggling
because, to answer it,
I'm going to give away
something in the book.
But do you want me
to give it away?
Yeah, all right.
So there was nowhere, OK.
I would go to the
library, sneak around,
try to figure out
the card catalog.
I don't know if you
even know what that is.
And then you'd get
there, and you'd
get to where it's supposed to
be, and the book's not there.
And it would be some
type of medical journal
that just had a definition.
It didn't have anything.
So I couldn't find anything.
So what I did was, in "The
Silence of the Lambs," Lecter,
when he's telling Starling
the history of Buffalo Bill,
he mentions three places where
there are gender clinics.
So I looked those up.
I think I was able to go in the
library and find phone numbers.
And I was living at
home at the time.
So I'd be so scared.
I'd have to do it when no one
was around, get on the phone
and call these places
and say, can you
send me some information
from your clinic?
So my therapist at the
time, who is not the one I
was talking to you about--
this was a different
one that I saw
first, who had no experience.
She says, send them to my
office and you can pick them up.
Don't worry.
I mean, I don't want an envelope
that says, Center for Gender
Reassignment, you know, and my
mom gets the mail and is like,
what?
So I had it sent to her office.
And she'd call me to tell
me I could pick them up
when they came in and
I went to get them.
And the envelopes
were all opened.
And I'm like, who opened these?
She goes, I did.
I'm like, bitch.
And she's like, well,
I figured, if we're
going to talk
about it, we should
know the same information.
And I was like, you whore.
So I am in the car.
I am so mad.
And I get home.
And I'm just about-- and I'm
trying to rationalize it.
I'm like, OK, it's a federal
offense, what she just did.
But I understand if she's
trying to be helpful.
Then I pull the packets out.
And she has taken the liberty
of highlighting everything
negative, or risky, or scary.
And keep in mind you
guys, there was--
you couldn't print anything out.
That was all I had.
So whenever I photocopied
it, her highlights
are there for
everyone else that I'm
trying to share something with.
The only other information
I had was a great article
that was in an issue
of "The New Yorker."
And I saved that and
I photocopied that.
And that was a tool
that I used when
I was telling people and
coaching people on how
to tell other people.
And I'd say, give them
this article, and use that.
But it was tough.
It was tough.
Nowadays, there is so
much information out
there it's crazy.
AUDIENCE: Can I ask
a second question?
CHRIS EDWARDS: Yes.
AUDIENCE: Thinking
back of when you
were a little child, five years
old and your grandma said,
sorry, kid, you can't be a man.
CHRIS EDWARDS: Right.
AUDIENCE: Would you-- my
daughter is 3 and 1/2,
almost four, and I was thinking,
if she came up to me saying I
want to be a boy, I
would put it off as, OK,
she's saying this like,
I want to be a fish, or--
you know, it's just one--
CHRIS EDWARDS:
There's a difference.
There's a difference between
saying I want to be, and I am.
OK, so this is a big thing now.
There's a lot of people--
both sides on, are kids
transitioning too young?
What's going on here?
And you look for persistence,
insistence, and consistency
with kids.
And if a child is saying I
am a boy, I am-- it's not,
I want to be a boy.
Why do you want to be a boy?
Well, boys get to play
football, and I love football.
I mean, it could be
a number of reasons.
But when it's I am, and they're
very adamant and insistent,
and it doesn't change?
That's when you know, OK,
something might be going on.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
CHRIS EDWARDS: Yeah.
Hi.
AUDIENCE: You tell a really
compelling personal story,
and I find it very fascinating.
I also find it very political.
You look at what was done
at South Carolina's HB2,
for example, and the way
they spoke about it-- it's
very different than your
story about knowing at age 5
that something is seriously
wrong, fundamentally
wrong with you.
Although not knowing how to--
CHRIS EDWARDS: I wouldn't say--
I would never say
to someone, there's
something mentally
wrong with you.
AUDIENCE: I didn't say
mentally, I said fundamentally.
CHRIS EDWARDS:
Oh, fundamentally.
I didn't hear the fun.
I missed the fun in fundamental.
OK.
AUDIENCE: So how
would you tackle that?
How would you reach those people
who are so very opposed to--
caricature or--
CHRIS EDWARDS: Stereotype.
AUDIENCE: --stereotype
of what you went through?
CHRIS EDWARDS: This
is the problem.
So--
AUDIENCE: You were
in advertising.
You have some tools
for this, right?
CHRIS EDWARDS: Yeah,
well, here's the thing.
I am not an activist.
That's not my deal.
So I'm on the board of greater
Boston PFLAG, and I help--
the way I help the caused
by sharing personal stories.
To me, that's how you
change minds, right?
It's very different.
It's very hard to hate someone.
Like, could you hate me
after you heard my story?
It's very hard, when someone
shares that personal thing,
and for someone to hate them.
And it's-- I find that people
retain the message and learn
better relating to
somebody's personal story,
rather than sitting them
down and saying, OK,
here's a gender 101 class,
or read this pamphlet.
And so for me, that's how
I help-- sharing my story,
writing this book.
I would send them my book.
But I'm not going to be the one
out there lobbying with signs.
That's not me.
There are plenty
of other people who
do that for the
community, but that--
that isn't me.
And a lot of people
ask me that question.
But I think that
you just have to do
what you feel comfortable
doing, and I am not
comfortable doing that.
So I try to help in other ways.
So there's-- and I'm involved in
organizations that are involved
in all of that.
And I help them
with their websites.
And I do all kinds
of stuff for them.
But this is, for me, being
on the front line, that's--
the activism is not
really my thing.
But it is unfortunate,
because that's--
these ignorant people
that are making these laws
they're dropping it
down to the bathroom
and how oh, they're
all perverts!
All the trans
people are perverts!
And they're going to molest
everyone in the bathroom.
There's never been one instance
of that ever happening.
But, you know, they go on fear.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]